je suis pas dans les pages jaunes si
vous avez des problèmes avec quelqu'un
vous pouvez faire appel à moi
jackson aimait quand tu verras le
docteur non dits lui telle fracture
spiroïdale durera du chant inspiré le
travail du ministère de la justice ainsi
amelia est en danger retrouvez là il
protégeait la marque djakeli je veux tu
retrouves 1 milliard tu bouges pas vous
avez vu cette fille qu'est ce que je
gagne moi il arrêtera de faire ça
pourquoi ça
et vraiment le pire détective du monde
le pire du monde personnel souffert même
monde a souffert non ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'ils sont morts rapidement ils
ont rien dû sentir